just great to see you here for the garda
screening of mature do tonight what was
it like reuniting with Amy and Alexis on
much to do and also if you could make
another Shakespeare film after this
which would be the next one you'd be
dying to do well obviously I you know
reuniting with Amy and alexis is
something I try to do as often as
possible I've been wanting to make this
movie for years they really are my
couple um and if I had to do another one
had to I should say it got to you know
you can't get away from Hamlet hits his
ghost that haunts me now of course it's
loser stuff going on with you we've got
agents of shield coming up we've got
Avengers 2 what can fans expect from
each of those well hopefully the same
thing they can expect from this a lot of
humor a lot of humanity Avengers will be
slightly more splodey than much ado
about nothing shield will sort of land
in the middle you know it's a very sort
of you know feet on the ground human
drama about the world with superheroes
and not so much a grand epic of saving
the world so I'm very excited about both
we've heard that some al Jackson it said
that he'd like a little role in shield
and so they think that's likely and also
what about Robert Downey jr. returning
for Avengers 2 well as far as Robert I'm
not in on that but I I'm optimistic as
far as Sam uh I guess he could audition
I read him I'd read him have you know or
I'd have someone read him and I'd look
at the tape for real it boards that
thanks so much is baking tins thank you
you